What is the processes
that they go through
in their particular
cultural space to cope
when there's adversity?
You know, protective factors or the mechanisms,
the processes that systems at different levels
whether that's an education system, or an
individual child, or indeed even a political
system?
I'm interested in how
people perceive their
own resilience
and how they understand their
capacity and their agency
to deal with different
types of shocks,
and disturbances, and to
actually affect change you know,
in positive
ways.
You can either ask individuals to change,
but actually the truth is that you can also
help people through a lot of period of change
by changing the environments around them,
by creating more facilitative communities,
better social policies, better transportation systems.
It's less of a burden on the individual to
wake up every morning and say okay, I've got
to cope with this new world because that new
world is just going to facilitate that gentle
nudge in the right direction.
I think that CIFAR gives us this great opportunity
to tackle some of these big, global challenges
and it also is really encouraging us to be
quite bold and to really move outside our
comfort zones and I think that some of the
intractable problems that we've been talking
about over the last few days where we think
ah, coming together and bringing these different
disciplinary perspectives and developing this
multi-systemic approach can really help to
answer some of these tricky questions.
And suddenly you're talking about these very
complex models of watching systems adapt,
and transform when they're under stress so
that they are more sustainable and indeed
more promoting of health and wellbeing.
[Music]